بعد اكتشاف استعداد الاصابه بمرض الزهايمر
اعلن نجم هوليود الاسترالي كريس هيمسورت
البلد من العمر 39 عاما انه يخطط للتوقف
عن تمثيل وربما الاعتزاله المبكر جاء هذا
القرار بعد خدوعه لفحوص دقيقه اثبتت ان
لديه استعدادا وراثيا للاصابه
عوامل وراثيه تجعله اكثر عرضه للاصابه
بعشر مرات مقارنه باي شخص اخر
واكد انه يرغب في انهاء شخصيه الثور التي
يجسدها في عالم مارفل السينمائي قبل ان
يتم تشخيصه بشكل رسمي بالزايمر ليضع نهايه
ممتازه للشخصيه قبل فوات الاوان حسب قوله
هذا الاعلان سلط الضوء على مرض العصر
الصايمر الذي بات لا يعرف عمرا وقد يصيب
الاشخاص في سن صغيره فيما يعرف
المبكر المزيد مع كلامي
يؤثر تاثيرا كثيرا على اي مرحله عمريه لكن
الاشخاص المصابين بدائي الزهايمر مبكر
يواجهون بعض التحديات الفريده من نوعها
زاء صهيم المبكر بشكل غير شائع من الخلف
ويصيب الاشخاص الذين تبلغ اعمارهم اقل من
65 عاما يصنعها 5 الى 6% من الاشخاص
المصابين بداء الزهايمر بالاعراض قبل سن
الخامسه 62 ويشعر معظم الاشخاص المصابون
باعراض المرض عندما تتراوح اعمارهم بين
الثلاثين والستين عاما لا يعرف الخبراء
تحديدا السبب وراء اصابته بعض الاشخاص
بالمرض في سن المبكره عن غيرهم لكنهم
يرشحون حدوث طفرات في احد الجينات التي
يمكن ان تورث لفرد اخر من العائله وقد تدل
اصابه احد الوالدين
مبكر على احد هذه التغيرات في الجينات
يتميز داء الزهايمر بخصائص مختلفه قليلا
هذا الاشخاص الاصغر سنا والتي قد تؤدي الى
تشخيص الخاطئ وتاخير العلاج المناسب الامر
الذي ينتج عن اثار سلبيه على جوده الحياه
ويعد التشخيص ضروري لاتخاذ القرارات
المهمه في المسائل الماليه والقانونيه قبل
فوات الاوان فقد يخسر المصممون علاقاتهم
او وظائفهم وبالتالي فقدان لمصدر دخلهم
نتيجه تشخليهم بهذا المرض بينما لا يزالون
في سن العمل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من المنامه ينضم الينا استشاري المخ
واستاذ عالم المناعه عمر بخير بروفيسور
يسعد صباحك نورنا دائما صباح العربيه اهلا
بك معنا بدنا نتحدث عن الزهايمر لدى صغار
او لذي صغار السن من هم في سن اصغر من
المعتاده الذين يسيبهم الزهايمر حديثنا
اكثر عن الزهايمر مبكر
يا صباح الخير وفي البدايه التهنئه الحاره
للمنتخب السعودي على هذا الفوز العظيم
الذي سيظل في ذاكره الجميع حتى من لديهم
الزهايمر شفاه الله ههه
كبار السن لكن في بعض الحالات يصيب صغار
السن في اعمار يعني ما بعد 35 الى 50
والسبب في ذلك وجود تحورات او طفرات جينيه
في نوعين من الجينات همم
الجيل الاول يعني يكون نسبه احتمال
الاصابه به تتراوح من 20 الى 25% اما
الجيل الثاني فهو يشفر لي ثلاثه بروتينات
ومن يحمل طفرات في هذا الجيم همم احتمال
المصابه قد تصل الى 100% اه بطل ما يساعد
على
يعني لديهم هذه القابليه الجينيه همم عدم
تمرين الذاكره الحاله النفسيه يعني
المؤثرات الاخرى همم نقص بعض الفيتامينات
بعض المواد الاكسده فهذا
يعجل بحدوث الزهايمر اللي يكون في وقت
مبكر لدى من لديهم هذا الاستعداد الوراثي
او الجيم بروفسل معز احنا كمان اشتقنا لك
يعني كنا نشوفك كثير في فتره كورونا وفي
نشاط الاخبار واشتقنا هيك نشوف طلتك على
العربيه هذا اولا بعيده عن كورونا اكيد
بعيدا
وان شاء الله تكون دائما اخبار ايجابيه
ولكن مش نتيجه ايجابيه كمان لاكورونا همم
انا نسيت السؤال شو كان السؤال اوكي
سؤالي يقول شو هي الاعراض اللي بتشكل جرس
انذار للفرد او للشخص انه قد يصاب
بالزهايمر في المستقبل القريب وعامر صغير
اهم شيء يعني عندما يلاحظ الاخرون ان هناك
تغيرات
في سلوك هذا الفرد وفي ذاكرته عاده عندما
هو يلاحظ كثيرون يقولون اننا سنصاب
بانزهايمر واننا بدانا ننسى ولا نتذكر هذا
الذي يعني يتعرض له الكثيرون حتى صغار
السن في عمر المراهقه فهو بسيارتي من من
يعني طبيعه الحياه الله
يعني التي غيرت كثيرا من الاشياء والتلوث
البيئي والتلوث الالكتروني هذا لا يعني
انه الزهايمر ليس هناك ههه يعني علامات
تؤكد تماما انه الزهايمر همم لكن اول مؤشر
هو عندما يلاحظ همم الاقربون لدى هذا
الشخص ان ان بعض السلوكه قد تغير انه اصبح
لا يهتم بنفسه انه اصبح لا يستطيع يعني
اداء بعض المهام همم حتى يعني بسيطه همم
هذا هو مؤشر
همم لكن الان هناك يعني بعض الفرصات
الدقيقه في السابق كان لابد ان تعمل يعني
رنين مغناطيسي وظيفي واا اشياء متقدمه او
ما يعرف بالبيت الاسكان لمعرفه ترسبات
البروتينات في خلايا الذاكره لكن همم يعني
هذا العام ثم ردد اكتشافات يعني تجعل يعني
همم التشخيص اكثر سهوله وفي السابق كانت
تشخيص الا بعد الوزاره والان هناك ايضا
علاجات جديده يعني حتى يعني هذا
همم عليه ان لا يستسلم ان هناك الان اجسام
مضاده ههه
ترسب بالبروتينات عم يبطل استخدامها اذا
تاكد انه الزهايمر يعني التشخيص او ان هذه
الجيل الموجود هل هو فعال ام لا يعني حتى
وجود التحورات في
الجينات
لكن ترسبات البروتينات الان يمكن اجراء
فحوصات عليها في الدم اذا وجدت هذه
البروتينات المتكسره الدم بواسطه التقنيات
حديثه اا يمكن له ان ياخذ بعض العلاجات
التي تمنع يعني تكسرها
في خلايا الذاكره
استاذ علم المناعه البروفيسور معزه عمار
بخير شكرا لك